well Marvel Studios and Sony has a lot
of plans for Spider-Man moving forward
in the MCU in the Sony spiderverse and
even in the animated spiderverse it
looks like and for those who are worried
about the future of Spider-Man after
Avengers Secret Wars don't worry he's
going to be a major part of the MCU
moving forward and it looks like Miles
Morales is also going to be coming in
and is going to be a major part of the
Spider-Man world so a lot to talk about
but first first big thank you to Marvel
contest of Champions for sponsoring this
video you all may know that I love this
game I have been casually playing this
game for years it's been around for a
long time but they keep coming up with
amazing updates and adding amazing
characters to make it just as good as it
was all those years ago the game now has
over 250 characters and what's awesome
is December is going to be packed with
events in Marvel's contest of Champions
including the game's 9-year anniversary
there's three big events that are coming
one is the onslaught event wielding the
powers of both Professor Xavier and
Magneto he's going to be a super strong
champion and a challenge to Summoners
and then we have a really hilarious
holiday themed event I'm not that guy in
a red suit where Red Guardian assembles
a team to put an end to mistaken Santa
Claus letters and of course to top it
all off as I mentioned we have the
anniversary event from December 10th
through the 17th where there are going
to be a lot of amazing Awards you can
get plus rotating quests to enhance your
Champions it's going to be packed in
December so if you want to try it out or
you want to get back into it you can use
the link in my description down below to
download it it is free to download on
the App Store and Google and start to
have an amazing time now in regards to
Tom Holland Spider-Man he is going to be
pretty much the main character moving
forward in the MCU according to The
Insider my time to shine hello who
talked about this about a week ago Tom
Holland will be the lead of the next two
Avengers films so both the King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars there was a
little bit of panic there was some fear
out there that Spider-Man might not make
it past Avengers Secret Wars and this
was because of a few things we know that
Marvel Studios is going to be rebooting
the MCU at least a soft reboot and we've
heard from Joanna Robinson the author of
MCU the reign of Marvel Studios that
Kevin is pretty much going to take
this soft reboot as an opport
opportunity to kind of cut out what
doesn't work and keep what does work but
don't worry Spider-Man Works he's been
working extremely well for the MCU and
for Sony for a pretty long time now with
the homecoming Trilogy being an absolute
knock out of the park for Marvel and
Sony's plus the projects that Spider-Man
has appeared in in the MCU as well have
done incredibly well he is one of the
most loved characters of all time so
even after Avengers Secret Wars Tom
Holland is going to be sticking around
as Spider-Man in fact if what we have
heard about his contract is true he'll
have two more Spider-Man films to
complete after secret War Spider-Man 5
and Spider-Man 6 we've only heard that
Spider-Man 4 is going to come before
Avengers Secret Wars so don't worry
about Spider-Man's future in the MCU
however we have heard that Miles Morales
is indeed going to be coming to the MCU
in the Spider-Man films soon however
this might be a little bit more
complicated than just regular Spider-Man
in the MCU because of the rights with
Sony Accord according to The Insider my
time to shine hello Miles Morales is
going to appear in the new Spider-Man
movies with Tom Holland meaning
Spider-Man 4 five and six in the MCU so
obviously that would bring miles into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe this is
awesome news and doesn't come as that
big of a surprise especially since
producer Amy Pascal confirmed on the red
carpet for Spider-Man across the
spiderverse to variety that a live
action Miles Morales project and
Spiderwoman project were both in in the
works right now and she stated you'll
see all of it so she confirmed a
liveaction Miles Morales is coming the
only question is are there going to be
two different miles morales's one in the
MCU and one in the Sony spiderverse
although it would be a very Sony move to
have two different versions of the
character exist in two different
universes we know that Marvel Studios
really fought against Sony to have
Spider-Man Tom Holland Spider-Man in the
Venom movies because they didn't want to
confuse people and make them confuse and
switch up the universes with each other
the Sony universe and the MCU so with
Miles coming to the MCU I would kind of
assume that it would be sort of the same
thing that they wouldn't want to get the
universes confused and he would simply
join the MCU and maybe if Sony wanted to
at some point in time they could bring
him over we know Sony is trying to build
up to a pretty big spider get in spider
verse event in which Tom Holland
Spider-Man will probably jump over as
well plus we are getting more and more
teases for Spider-Man in Sony
spiderverse Madame Webb is even
introducing Ben Parker Peter Parker's
father but could they have plans to
introduce their own characters outside
of the MCU that remains a mystery right
now either way it looks like there is
going to be a lot coming for Spider-Man
and Miles Morales and according to my
time to shine hello miles is entering
the MCU and this is most likely and
sadly happening so Miles Morales can
actually take the spot of the main
Spider-Man and the MCU if what we heard
about Tom Holland's contract is true
then Tom Holland is only going to have
two or three films after Avengers Secret
Wars and then he is most likely going to
be done with the character at that point
in time he'll have played the character
for a pretty long time and he's already
stated multiple times that as an actor
he doesn't want to play the character
for too long and he would love for
somebody else to come in somebody young
and very passionate to take over that
mantle and it looks like that character
that's going to come in could be Miles
Morales instead of Simply replacing a
Peter Parker we are going to get a Miles
Morales now the only question really is
when exactly is Miles Morales going to
come into the MCU well The Insider my
time to shine hello last week simply
said in Tom Holland's Spider-Man movies
talking about multiple movies so one
would assume the latest that we'll see
miles is Spider-Man 5 maybe he doesn't
come in Spider-Man 4 the next film but
even speaking storywise and continuity
wise it would make sense to have him at
least show up in Spider-Man 5 especially
if he is going going to take the spot of
Tom Holland Peter Parker it would make
sense to introduce him in five start
setting him up start building him up and
then in six which would be Tom Holland's
farewell officially pass on the mantle
to him so of course there is the
possibility that Miles could show up in
Spider-Man 4 however he just might not
dawn a Spider-Man suit yet he could meet
Peter Parker at Feast since that is a
story that we're all familiar with and
they set up feast in the last film
Spider-Man no way home so he might cameo
in Spider-Man 4 and of course there is
the possibility that that he could get
involved with Peter Parker Spider-Man as
soon as Spider-Man 4 but if they
gradually work up to it we're probably
looking at an introduction to miles just
miles in Spider-Man 4 then in Spider-Man
5 we see Miles Morales as Spider-Man
training under Peter Parker and then in
Spider-Man 6 he'll take on the mantle of
the new Spider-Man in the MCU and if
they're just kind of introducing his
character in the MCU in Spider-Man 4
then he probably won't show up in secret
Wars however it does kind of look like
the Sony animated spiderverse could be
connecting with the MCU after all and we
could see maybe an animated Miles
Morales show up in Avengers Secret Wars
I think this would be really really cool
to see in fact they could do that and
have whoever is going to be playing the
liveaction Miles Morales in the MCU
simply play The Animated Miles Morales
when he jumps over into the liveaction
world in secret Wars that would be
really really cool this would mean we'd
have to wait until Spider-Man 5 to get
introduced to him but it would set it up
in a very nice way Tom Holland
Spider-Man could meet Miles Morales in
secret Wars and then in Spider-Man 5 he
could run into miles in the MCU and say
hey I know your secret I'm Spider-Man
let's talk plus not to mention it seems
like Spider-Man across the spider-verse
showed us the Multiverse as Loki created
it at the end of Loki season 2 with the
igdrasil tree if you take a look it
looks pretty identical so perhaps Marvel
Studios and Sony were talking before
across the spiderverse came out and said
hey these are our plans this is what we
plan to do if you want to kind of line
up a little bit perhaps these are plans
to have the two universes cross over in
secret Wars or perhaps they're just
trying to keep some continuity in
between the two universes even if it
doesn't mean a big crossover however I
would be pretty shocked if we didn't see
at least one character from the Sony
animated spiderverse cross over into the
MCU for Avengers Secret Wars and
hopefully that does happen fingers cross
but go ahead and let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below Spider-Man's future is bright the
future of Miles Morales is bright and
perhaps we'll see a crossover between
the Sony spiderverse and the MCU
relatively soon but let us know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video And
subscribe and if you subscribe and leave
a comment you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for a chance to win a
PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items and some DC items the winner picks
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof